was very charming could charm the socks
off anybody that he would meet uh
and he was essentially just a good
normal person
he's left a big hole in all of our lives
because he was really good fun
he's a really good fun person to be with
jenny is grieving for her twin brother
just 42 and super fit
john died fighting for air on a hospital
incubator
after catching kovid he deteriorated
really quite quickly he tested positive
on the tuesday
and by saturday he went into hospital in
an ambulance
john refused to take the vaccine it was
his last regret
he said that he really regretted not
having the vaccine and he was beating
himself up
and that he wished that he had done it
do you hold
the people who spread misinformation
about the vaccine responsible for your
brother's death
i do we should be angry at the people
who are
spreading the disinformation about the
vaccine
the uk has one of the best vaccine
take-ups
in the world but there is a worry
vaccine hesitancy
in some younger people is driving a rise
in hospital admissions
nhs leaders say 18 to 34 year olds
now account for a fifth of all
seriously ill-covered patients that's
because it's people under 40
who have the highest infection rates
according to their latest
government data and if we look at the
hospital admissions
in the 15 to 44 age group we can see
there is an
uptick in cases the vaccine
has led to a significant fall in
hospital admissions for the over 60s
but hospital beds are now being taken up
by younger patients intensive care
consultant dr zudin puthichiri
said his younger covered patients risked
long-term damage to their health these
young people when they go home
they're going to struggle to do simple
things in their lives like go to the
toilet by themselves
get out of bed by themselves feed
themselves
that's the real danger we have here it's
not just death that
they're facing it's disability dr
puticherry's warning
has come too late for john his
heartbroken family
are sharing his devastating story
in the hope that it will save lives
this could happen to you you could be
one of the unlucky ones and my brother
was unlucky
statistically this shouldn't have
happened to him ashish joshi
sky news